thank you guys welcome to the second day
of the talks I'm delighted to be here
from San Francisco weather is so much
better here than it is in San Francisco
and I just want to take a couple of
minutes to call out some very special
people I realized that PI data is the
first PI data Miami is the first
conference and I want to call out to
Alex and an Iran and Mark and all the
volunteers there done a fabulous job in
putting this together so give them a big
hand guys so thank you I'm really
excited to talk about ml flow which is
the open source product that was
actually I should open source project
that was created by Matias R he also
happens to be the original creator of
Paju spark to share with you what's it
all about you probably heard about
machine learning lots of cycle
throughout the conference so I wanted to
share what that's all about and
hopefully you guys can also be part of
this particular project it being an open
source that we'd love to hear your
feedback at the end and also take a
survey so that way we can actually get
an incredible feedback from all machine
learning data scientist and developers
over here a little bit about myself I
had the good fortune to work as some of
the disruptors and some of the
innovators company of the Silicon Valley
most recently I've sort of transitioned
into being an advocate because I feel
that you guys the developers are the new
king makers and having the interaction
with you to convey and converse with you
is actually an important part of my job
and nothing pleases me more than to
share some of the new things that
actually emerge out of the open-source
community with people like you who
actually make a difference and I'm of
conviction that innovation actually
happens in collaboration node in
isolation so I think it's important to
have you as part of the committee hence
the open source projects all around the
world are taking a significant uptick in
its contributions this is what I'm going
to share with you over the next couple
of few minutes give you an overview of
some of the challenges of what machine
learning safeguard which are kind of
unique they're different from your
software development edit compile life
cycle and some of you probably live
through it on a daily basis and give you
an idea how ml flow TECO's that's not
that's very unique but it's sort of
gathered the information and gathered
the the mechanisms and the strategy from
all this other projects and then combine
them to that but the important thing was
that we want to do it in an open manner
and I think that's important part of it
where you guys come into the play and
I'll talk about briefly what the MFO
components are and give you a developer
experience and what is it like to use
some of its API and hopefully share with
you the roadmap where you guys can
actually contribute energy to make a
difference as well and hopefully we
might have some questions and answer if
not just corner me on the side put a
torch to my hair now hoping to take some
feedback back to our engineering team so
I'll make an assertion that machine
learning is a level is is is complex and
it is complex not so much because the
algorithms behind it are difficult or
the math behind is difficult all the
theory behind it difficult what's
difficult about is is the evolution of
the model in the interview process and
the cumbersome way and you can't have
the track things to make sure that the
model that emerges at the end of the
cycle is something that you actually
feel confident about deploying and you
feel confident in its in its metric and
its evaluation and it's in its
predictions and that sort of introduces
a lot of different parameters and of
changing things that actually happen in
that entire lifecycle so if you look at
your quintessential machine learning
cycle this is something all of you
probably do on a daily basis if you're
building a model the problem comes in
because the fact that as a developer or
as a as a data scientist you want to use
the best of the tools you know whether
you're actually doing data preparations
whether using library for tuning with
the actually deployment in the
environment and you want and after
you've deployed it you actually want to
monitor that and these stages have its
own challenges that you actually had to
tackle with that you have to address it
in the manner that you feel that you use
the best of the tools so let's look at
the first one it's tuning when you're
preparing data data comes from different
sources it comes in different format it
comes it's dirty you actually have to do
all the cleaning here to do all the
feature engineering you might be working
with the data engineers to actually do
that but at the same time you might be
using databases you might be using Kafka
you might be using kinases you might
using some homegrown tool that you
actually tuned in a manner so that you
actually get the data quite fast so
tuning is actually quite important and
here to somehow keep that in track you
have to remember that how you actually
used it in case you have to reproduce
the data and that's actually changing
the first is tuning tuning also comes
into into place when you're actually
training the model you know we talked
about I think if you actually attended
Zack Browns
talk yesterday tuning is actually
important because you you want to change
your regulation parameters you want to
do a hyper hyper parameter switching you
actually want to do change your learning
rate to see how we can actually twitch
the needle and that's the important part
tuning comes into play in all the
different algorithms and all the
different machine libraries they show
you none how do you track of all those
things right because you might have
hundreds of experiments you might have
tune the parameters very differently so
you have to tune them in a manner and
remember that the first one was
configuration the second one is tuning
the third is scale right big day that
deals with scale your machine learning
algorithm dingbat scale AI deals with
scale you talk about you you heard about
what Clement talked about it's all about
data right the more data you have the
more confidence you have in your in your
training and therefore yep you have to
be able to deal with scale so scale
actually has to has to be an important
part in the entire lifecycle you have to
have an infrastructure that they can
actually take in a huge amount of
training day and a huge in my validation
data so you can actually feel confident
about your model the third is deployment
you know what do you do after your trend
this particular model and after you want
to hand it off to the DevOps people you
want you want to make sure that the
model that you actually deployed is the
one that you actually trained with the
right data the trained with the right
hyper parameters tuning you train with
the same data and you remember now you
want to be able to deploy it so make
sure that when you deploy it when you're
monitoring in you're actually looking at
that in a scale so those are sort of you
know some of the challenges you actually
have to deal with and then finally you
know we are living in
in in what I will hold the data as I
skies of the world where data really is
an important part of it and if you learn
if you if you're living in Europe GDP
are is an important part of it and
governance is an important part of it
you heard yesterday from Shang how that
governance and provenance is an
important part of it and they are
actually working order you heard about
Jacob talked about the same thing the
governance is actually important part
which is the tail end of your cycle
where you can actually do predictably we
can actually do auditability
so these are all different life cycles
right which is very different from your
normal compiled edited life cycle and
here's a validation of somebody who
actually we worked with is one of the
very popular I can't give the name of
the company but we shared when we were
exploring what we can actually do with
Emma flow we shared this idea with them
and it's saying you know we build
hundreds and thousands of model a day
it's not only one language that we use
it don't leave one frame with a be use
it's not only one infrastructure that we
use we use the Marriott set of tools
they even want to be able to reproduce
that in a manner that I'm confident when
I deploy that I can move the needle and
that actually resonated quite a bit with
a lot of developers is that we actually
need that so how do we how do we do that
and you might ask Jules hang on what's
the problem right if this is such a
problem and all of you are sitting over
here doing things on daily basis then
why why somebody actually hasn't done
this why this problem hasn't been solved
it turned out it has right it's not that
it hasn't been done it's not that this
is something new it's not that we have
come up with this idea it is that people
are actually have built all this custom
frameworks and they have there been the
harbingers they actually have put in
standard they have standardized how do
you do their preparation how to do
training how do they deploy model and it
actually works great when you work with
this companies I remember an anecdote I
was running a barrier punches for Meetup
and I had this data scientists from the
Facebook who actually came over and gave
a talk on how they do sentiment analysis
on the newsfeed and he gave a great
presentation at the end of the talk I
asked him you know can you talk to
whether you use Apache spark or either
use Emily will you actually use your own
machine learning libraries or what
infrastructure you use and you're
stumped
you couldn't answer the question not
that he was in fact he just couldn't
answer the question because what the FB
learner had extracted all that right
that expected all that and they'd given
him or the data scientists who actually
work a declarative language in wind they
say okay I want here's my data set here
is my declarative way I want to use it I
want to use this particular algorithm i
when you see regression I want to do
classification here's my validation data
here's my training training data you
figure out you create the model you run
it when it's done send me a notification
I'm done right so that's level of
abstraction they do that Michelangelo is
another one
where we're over actually produces and
deploys mortal on daily basis and
they'll standardize the same thing you
know they use the same mechanism about
data preparation do the training and in
deployment Google tea effects is is
another one so what's wrong with that I
think the problem is is when you when
you leave the company you lose that IP
property or you're stuck with an
infrastructure right if I'm working at
Google and I'm very much used to the
Borg how many have heard about the Borg
at Google right Borg was the massive
infrastructure in which they were
actually doing scale now when you think
about scale who you think about you
think about Google right because they
deal with scale so they had this
particular infrastructure called Borg
whose grandchild is kubernetes which is
an orchestration engine what Borg was
the one that actually allowed it when
people left board
I mean people left Twitter and people
left Google and went to work somewhere
else
the first idea popped into the head was
god I wish I had worked with me because
I could do all that same thing with the
guy who actually liked the left Facebook
said I wish I actually had that
particular infrastructure so we thought
that would is it we can actually learn
from this but the key imperative for us
was that we wanted to do it in an open
manner with the community to make sure
that they can choose the tools that want
they can choose the language they want
they can deploy Matt deployed in
environment warned if they move on what
company a to company be they take the
intellectual property with them and they
can reproduce that and that is the
benefit of doing things in an open
manner so how do we address that well
the answer was
we set down with the community we sit
down with all this key stakeholders we
say can we actually do this in an open
manner and that's what my tears are and
the jury team and the rest of us who
actually sit down with these guys over a
pub and drink lots of beers and say okay
you know let's let's let's sort
something out
and that's what we came up we said the
imperatives we're doing that we should
be able to use any libraries that we
want we should be able to run it
anywhere on my machine because most of
the developers do think on the machine I
should be able to run locally I should
be able to do it remotely and the most
important parrot --iv is it has to be
simple it has to be easy to use and the
developer experience has to be
phenomenal because you can't really get
anything done if you don't please the
developer because they're all press
today are the kingmakers and I think
it's very important to actually do that
and as a result of that there were two
design principles behind this one was
that we want to make sure that that we
provided the API to developers just like
the API is they've actually made a
difference in the world if you look at a
little bit of the history if you look at
UNIX how it actually pull or afraid it
as a platform to write application was
because of its C simple interface to the
application you could actually write
kernel libraries you can actually write
kernel module you can write window
managers but they've all built on top of
this Enix interface they had other tools
they had text they had yak they had I'm
dating myself but that's what I actually
had right these were if you look at Java
how it actually evolved it was because
of the fact that they had Java API you
can actually write application of all of
that look what happened to because of
that you got Hadoop we got now JVM that
actually has given us a bunch of spark
Apache spark library has been an
appealing thing because it because he
was thought about as a develop first API
so we want to make sure that we actually
get them the api's
that when they build the models when
they deploy more they can use rest which
is very simple you're not you know
you're not tied to any particular
platform language just use HTTP protocol
or they can use command line to do that
so there was a design philosophy API is
easkey the second one was we want to
make sure that things were modular and
what I mean by modular we didn't want to
do have an entire monolithic tool that
you can actually use it and if you don't
use one part of it you can't really use
here to use
entire thing so we wanted to have the
distinct and disparate tools the people
can actually use say for example
tracking experiments so they can use I
just want to package my particular model
and I want to deploy it or I just want
to you know do more than management so
we want to make sure that that they were
distinctive and and that could actually
select any of the components that we
actually have so that was the imperative
and those are the principal components
in the design philosophy the materia and
the group were actually thinking about
and so what are the components right so
they're three very distinctive and
selected components that any of you can
actually use it one is the ml for
tracking API and the tracking allows you
to record your experiments you heard
about it Clement talked about today how
you actually experimentation is an
important part of the life cycle if
you're running thousand experiments how
are you going to track all that right if
you're building let's say language
classification model you know you might
be tuning the parameters you might be
doing hyperthermia you might be using
all the different strategies to change
the model each and every model that you
actually run intuitively you want to
track exactly what went in and what went
out so that way if you want to reproduce
it it's very easy to capture that the
second word was the ability to actually
capture the project in such a way that
it becomes the unit of execution
independently right think about project
is nothing but a subset of a docker file
we need to care the docker file you can
actually deploy it anywhere you actually
want right so that's that that was that
was it the third one is the ml flow
models and models are different flavors
of model you can actually use so let me
just give you a quick sort of
illustration of what is life without the
ml for tracking idea think about this
particular pseudocode right if you
didn't have a tracking a PID what will
you do you will actually you know build
a particular model you will compute the
accuracy and then you would actually use
some sort of for loop to go and put that
in in a file somewhere or capture that
in a JSON file and then and then run you
know thousand times it becomes a bit
cumbersome over time right if you have
thousands of experiments how are you
gonna track that you know you put this
in the file or you might put it in SQL
and you might put some tags so you can
actually be searching but it becomes a
bit tedious what if you're expand you
what
in Peru and grants change now you
actually have to rerun again what if you
want to tune the parameters lets you you
regular s in parameter is different
let's say you actually have an
additional parameter that you want to
use to move the accuracy you go to
account for that what if your library
gets upgraded now you actually have to
now rebuild everything and make sure
that that you run through the experiment
what if the version of the code actually
changes so these are the things that you
actually had to worry about and so we
actually had to account all those things
and one of the things we actually
decided to do that that there should be
few cute concepts in tracking that
allows you to be able to monitor as
those concepts one is parameters when
are we actually doing a modal management
or modal tracking a mortal experiment
your sudden profit is are you going to
use right you can have some metrics that
you care about you know the accuracy is
the loss your loss function your your
prediction all those are area under the
code depending on what what algorithm
were optimize as they actually use they
will help the matric each model might
have adapting it Harris has the metric
tensor flow headers metrics all the
models that you actually use will have
some sort of a a metric that actually
matters that that's going to change the
needle you might have some tags and
notes that you want to convey to the guy
who's going to read the model especially
when you're handing off model to someone
else and the artifacts that you're gonna
store the files that make up the model
the data of the paths to the data where
where data is stored so you can
reproduce the model and the model type
you know whether it was a tensor flow
model is the Charis whether it was ml
late where they was psych it or not all
these different models that you want to
care about and finally the source code
that actually went into it now if you
take it one step forward and if you use
the MLA API it's very simple you just
import ml flow people install ml flow
and this happens to be a Python code
that's using tensorflow and I just use
the width with the the the standard
complex statement which start run and
now I'm actually doing the room and I'm
tracking the experiments I'm just you
know putting my parameters in I'm
putting my metrics in and finally I'm
logging the model which mean this is
going to be a tentacle model it is that
simple
really the tracking is is that simple
all the work is actually done for you so
if you take that algorithm before that
you were using JSON file and printer
and you use the ml flow it just becomes
very easy right you just import the
statement now you use the load
parameters to do that and then once you
have actually load the parameters you
can actually use ml for for tracking for
tracking UI so that's actually what
happens is that you you can actually go
into your entry into your ml flow
UI and actually find out what metrics
were logged what the model looks like
when was the motor run who was in run by
what does immortal soul ever look like
all there's actually given to you
because of tracking and tracking can be
done unto that you can actually ever
tracking so discerning remotely or we
can have a tracking server by default
when you do pip install that runs
locally under a directory called ml runs
and when you same a flow UI it's gonna
launch a flask a UI and give you the
ability to actually do that and that's
actually governed by your environment
variable where we actually have the
tracking so we're running so you can use
the you want to look at the experiment
in a very turbulent motor you can
compare you can compare the metrics of
you know model 1 versus model Tunis okay
I like this module I'm gonna use that
I'm going to deploy it or you can
actually use that programmatically so
that sort of in in essence is tracking
the second thing was the motivation was
project we wanted to make sure that one
of the principal propositions behind is
really that earlier who was they we want
to be able to use all this different
diverse set of tools right we want to
get the data scientist so the ml
developer or the developer the best tool
they he or she wants to use the best
language they're going to use now each
of these libraries has its own format to
store the model right now if you
actually try to encapture all the
different models we would have n by n
problem right because we have to support
all that it's no very different from
what Clement said earlier this morning
that the reason they went to Apache
error was because they wanted to have a
air about your arrow as the unifying
thing that that that that's that's
common to all the different libraries
that they can actually just use that so
we actually came up with this idea about
Emma for project it's really a packaging
format we just encapture what your
project looks like what the dependencies
are what is the you actually need to run
it and we just create a simple file it's
very similar to the Oracle file and so
the project essentially
and captures the specifications you can
actually run it locally and execute
remotely and the project file just looks
very simple just a directory on your
github that has your Condor environment
that says if I'm going to deploy this
particular model somebody who wants to
run this model what they will need then
we need the content environment and the
Condor will recreate just like the
Python where children are you'll
recreate your environment in this
particular sandbox and those are the
entry points for your program I can have
parameters that that that's going to run
whether it's my Python of main function
that's an entry point to the model or it
could be anything else right it could be
a Java code it could be you know some
shell script that you actually running
to do some authentication and then
giving a giving it to the Python to run
it and it's very simple I can actually
use ml for run git hub to my project and
then give the parameters that I want the
default parameter is $1 but I can
actually give a different parameter and
it will actually run that and we create
an experiment and then you'll be able to
see oh with these two new parameters
this is the results I got so not only
you as a developer who actually created
the original experiment you can actually
share with the rest of the community
through the gate project that's
currently where it is with different
parameters and they can actually run it
independently and share it so that's the
gist behind project and then finally I
talked about modal's right because we
wanted to have the distinct models and
one of the reasons we want to have this
because we won't be able to support all
this particular model and we captured
that model as a flavor we say this is
going to be a Python a PI function this
is going to be a tentacle model or a
Karass model or a scikit-learn or ml lib
and we captured that information so that
we can actually deploy it anywhere that
we actually want maybe actually running
Python or way understands that this is a
tensor flow model and I'm running on
kubernetes so I'm just going to load
that tense of our motor using the API
and then the predict function and if you
look at the project file I mean the
modal file it's very simple each run has
unique ID the time you actually created
the flavor that we actually supports if
it's tensorflow modal that's it we'll
say that this is actually tensorflow
and the directories estimator and there
is a function called predict that I'm
going to use once I load the model and
give the data that I need to get my
predictions and if I'm using a Python
function I'll load that as a Python and
if I'm deploying to Apache spark I can
actually use that as a UDF that's sort
of in essence what the model flavor are
and it is again very similar to what
what I would say in sort of dockerfile
it encapsulates that and that's sort of
the the reason behind Moodle so now here
through distinct model we talked about
the tracking we talked about the
encapsulation and capturing the model in
a unit of executions you can reproduce
it the important part of you want to
reproduce it with the parameters that
you actually saved and those were the
ones that he actually saved it's going
to run it whatever experiment ID then
you provide it's going to pick up the
parameters that you are actually saved
and then recreate the environment so you
know with certain amount of certainty
the given a model that you created last
week the parameters that you use the
tuning parameters use will be able to be
able to reproduce that so that essence
is is what it is so I will now sort of
switch a little bit and and and show you
how you can actually do that in encode
and if you want to take a picture of
these I have all the URLs available this
is where the the code is and that's
where they get repository where I have
the IMD classifier that I'm going to use
and the essence is that I'm going to use
I'm going to create three experiments
right the experiments are going to be
somebody missed that I'm going to
publish this slug and put it on PI data
as if you're that alright and in fact
the the guys actually have it
oops so I'm creating three modal's right
we have a base in my baseline motor we
always have a baseline model you want to
compare that we're gonna create
experiment one with all the different
parameters and then and then we're going
to use experiment two and they will find
out which one is the best and we'll try
to deploy it and see how it works how
much time I have ten minutes okay I'll
run through it quickly all right so
let's switch a little bit over here
one caution never drink beer the night
before you're giving a presentation
Jeff don't have happy hours a night
before ok so this is my particular
notebook oh my goodness now I think I
only have 10 minutes I'm not gonna run
this expense I have a pre-owned
experiment and believe me this is
actually works because it's gonna I only
have 10 minutes hours and make sure so
what I have over here is a Karass model
that's doing doing sentiment analysis
and this is the model that actually
takes the IMDB set by the way if you
haven't got this particular book by
France Chalet get it it's probably the
best Python book on on on deep learning
and I'm using IMDB sets which are about
15,000 reviews and just like the EM nest
data set I can just load the data in and
everything that actually has been
vectorized for me so I don't have to go
through creating tensors from my word
that and my weights all that is actually
given to it and so I'm just gonna use
that particular model experiment and all
over here I'm just importing my ml flow
my MD classifier and all the libraries
that I'm using it because I'm using a
Karass in the underlying the underlying
thing is the tensor flow engine and the
version that I have and these are all my
modules that I actually need I haven't
well I'm a flow client which is your
handle to anything they actually want to
do the tracking server and just run some
you know query experiments to find out
and this is my model that actually
created two my first my first model is
this one over here which actually takes
in the baseline is 16 units I'm gonna
run through 20 ebooks I'm gonna have a
binary classifier and then my output is
going to be the output from the sigmoid
function each layer actually uses in
value and the final one is a sigmoid
function and it gives them the
probability or whether this is a good
review or a bad review I'm gonna run
three experiments and when you run the
first experiment is going to go down to
the Amazon download the read it will run
through 20 you is create a sense of flow
or tensor board event so I can actually
manage the event it's going to log all
the events and everything I'll run it
for a while and you can believe me I
actually ran it just last night and then
I'm gonna run the Xperia member to
expiry to
actually changing the epochs and
changing the hidden layers and one of
the things that Francois recommends that
if you actually would do the experiment
maybe change the the number of dense
layers here maybe change the input of
the parameters that you are actually
going to put the hero change maybe the
the the the revenue function or the
optimize the function use something else
the reason binding Pro simply use MSE so
if you're going to do that with the
first second one and with the second
experiment I'm going to use now the
hidden layer to be three I'm going to
use my epochs to be twenty my output I'm
gonna change it 32 and my loss function
is going to be MSE and I usually the
regularization parameter is zero point
zero and I'm run that experiment and
it's going to go through all that and
they'll give me my accuracy and all that
right all this is actually tracking on
the on the UI so the next thing I'm
going to do is I'll go over to my UI and
I have three experiments right I've got
the first one that ran the last one with
MSE and the two ones that in each each
of these actually have their accuracy so
what I want to do is I'm going to
compare let's know what I wanted
so created it I'm going to compare those
three to see which one is the best one
so I'm going to compare then I can use
that to compare all my experiments right
so over here I get a nice little column
diagram that says these are the
parameters that you actually used you
know these are the metrics that you
actually care about and I can actually
figure out which one is actually better
so for example I care about the
validation laws and we can see that the
validation laws for this one was
comparable so probably it's not the best
one I can actually look at the the
validation laws for this I mean those
accuracy the validation loss of this one
and I realized that the MSE actually
gave me the best results right so I'll
probably choose that just works around
if I can get 90% accuracy in my
sentiment analysis I'm happy with that
right so we choose that particular model
as as the one that we actually have I
can go in there and actually look at the
individual experiment and see you know
how did the art effects look like I have
images over here and I can say well this
was my baseline thing that I actually
used plot later should create and I
stole that as part of it so you can
actually go in there and look at all the
artifacts that you have and you can
actually see that it's beginning to sort
of over feet at about you know five
epochs so we have an idea of how you
have your curves looks like I can
compare that with the with the
experimental UI
to see well you know it is is my is my
validation accuracy tracking along with
the training am I saying or fitting am I
seeing under fitting so you can actually
see the trend and you can actually do
all that and then finally once you
realize that okay I really care about
the the the eighty eighty nine percent
accuracy for my MSC optimizer and I know
the loss is very very small so I'm
getting a good accuracy I'm gonna use
that particular model to go ahead and
deploy it and then I'm gonna use that
predictions so we'll go ahead and by the
way you can actually also use tensorflow
right so i was i was using tensorflow
i'm intensive bore you can actually go
intensive board to look at all the
images so that's what the tensor board
looks like i can actually look at my
graphs
all right we keep on going and I'm gonna
I can reproduce experiment and the way I
reproduce the experiment is is I know
the UID right and it's running on the
tracking server and I know what my
tracking server is I'm just making it a
rest cold as they go in and you know
load this particular experiment and then
do some predictions so I read though
these experiments and I give a
particular prediction says you know this
is a five star movie awfully good movie
I would recommend it what is this gonna
happen there was a talk here yesterday
by China how we say one of the reasons
why lsdm does a better job or a
recurrent Network do a better job
because they keep track of the memory so
what do you do when you actually have a
context like that right this is a five
star movie all fully good right but if
awful is also cannot cannot it as a bad
one is probably going to get confused
because this is not a very surface
schedule the word work is just keeps
keeps a track of the frequency of the
word count so what do you think is gonna
get I do a prediction and I get about I
lost my
I get a buzz Europe went fine right it's
no it wasn't quite sure but he found her
when I rented this thing over here we'd
say is this is this is a great movie I
get 0.8 how much time do I have two
minutes again and then if I have a bad
movie that says this is an awfully movie
and he predicted right bird books it was
scary and and I got to 0.2 right so you
can actually do that in real time with
it with people you look in the click
stream you have deployed this particular
model you're happy with the MSC but then
you begin to realize that you know
there's something wrong over here you
know I mean that is a perfect sentiment
analysis of saying you know this is an
awfully good movie right or if I send
something like this is dope man what is
it gonna do right that's that's no
grandma clearly correct English but it's
being used I've seen you know advocates
tweeting this is dope I've seen Andrew
Inc saying this is dope man you should
try it out what do you do then right so
you have to somehow use another
algorithm and so one of the experiments
you can actually do is okay what do you
think the next algorithm would be to
make sense over here I used your typical
first text analysis you know tfiid or I
can use word wack what would be the next
experiment that I would want to conduct
anybody Zack you can answer that
question I could use in a recurrent
Network I can use you know lsdm so that
would be my next victim and I would go
to the same processor I would look all
the all the stuff so that's so in
essence is is your your mm flow in a
nutshell very easy to use just import
the library is you the three kinds of
like API is you got Python you got Java
and you got R as well and then going
back and finishing up my presentation
so basically you know this way we are
right now we just released 0.8 version
over here that actually has a lot of
faster improved area because we using
thousands experiments you won't be able
to look at the experience quite easily
you am able to search experiments by
parameters because if you have people
who have run thousand experiments you
might believe that you'll be able to use
the tags to do the searching so that has
been include we are extended the Python
model so if you actually let's say you
need ml label you use ml scikit-learn
anyone who stored it as it as an ml lib
flavor and now you actually want to use
that as a Python UDF so you can actually
provide arguments you can actually
deploy it at a spark UDF and then other
dependencies on Conda now we actually
store the Conda Conda environment within
the model so that it captures how you
can actually really produce that and we
are looking for your contribution how
you can actually get involved try pip
install get started there ok mutations
are greatly loads and lots of code
examples contribute go to the github
Emma flow let's pull a request you know
if you see something that's actually
missing that you are using on daily
basis that we have not adjusted we want
to hear from you and I think that's why
I'm here to actually share this with
Python community because python is one
of the first-class api's and this is
actually a great simple API to actually
use to do your tracking and the rest of
the sub we have a slack channel for you
to you know vent your frustrations and
then we actually have an ml for survey
that Matthias rreow put together and
sort of give an idea what's actually
coming up in 2019 and we want you to
take the particular survey and that
gives us a great feedback or what other
things you know I know a lot of people I
had a chat with yesterday and over the
course of two days have sort of
expressed you know some of the
frustration and some of the lemons that
I think is important and we want to
capture them we want to make sure that
you are an important part of the
community because this is an open source
project right this is not proprietary
and you can actually make a difference
if we're actually making a difference it
probably might be releasing one dot o
imminently probably by February but file
Apple require corapi I requested we
would look
we are very important we actually have
three big contribution our was a
completely committing effort right we
didn't have an our API but the guides
our studio said we have lot of data
scientists who use our API we're going
to be going to do a pull request so they
actually wrote wrote an M&A climb and
they fully integrated with our Java is
the same thing was it was was a
community we started with Python there
was no other of the API and some guys
say hey you know I'm a Java coder I
don't want to use Python or Scala
there's anything to say all right spyler
pull records and they did that we have
an mo flow client that actually uses
Java and we are working with Conda to
support Java so they can reproduce that
write a JVM and all that and so anything
do you actually see please share with us
and so in a nutshell you know this is
what I talked about it's light it's very
distinctive you can actually select the
component you actually want to use the
important thing is you can develop
locally and you can remotely do the
experimentation you can do it in the
cloud you can do it on premise which
again sort of reaffirms my early
assertions that we wanted to do this in
an open manner and the only way we can
actually do an open manner that don't
tie anything to particularly
infrastructure don't tie anything to
vendor do it in open-source that all of
you can actually use it whenever you
want however you actually want to use it
now those are sort of aspirations thing
you know but let's choose the common
let's be pragmatic let's choose the
common API they they are being used by
all of you so we can actually make that
part of it
and if San Francisco is on a bucket list
I'm the program Sheriff do come there's
15% discount for you guys and hopefully
to see you
in sunny Oh wintery San Francisco in
April it won't be as pleasant as this
one so thanks a lot I'll do any question
so we're actually out of time for
questions want to make sure everybody
else has their their opportunity to
speak so you can find Jules you're
hanging out for lunch I'm gonna hang out
you know yes a tutorial tomorrow morning
as well a different topic yeah I'm also
giving a tutorial tomorrow so hold the
pie torsion in my head and hopefully
I'll be able to answer you